he who has a why to live for
can bear almost any how
health so far outweighs all other
blessings of life better truly healthy
beggar is happier than a sick King
the most educated person
is the simplest one
the busier we are the more acutely we
feel that we live
the more conscious we are of life
prayers do not change the world
but prayers change people
and people change the world
rules for happiness
something to do someone to love
something to hope for
if you love something so much let it go
if it comes back it was meant to be
if it doesn't it never was
the most harmful thing is wanting to
avoid mistakes
happiness is nothing more than good
health and a bad memory
give a person everything that he desires
and at the same moment he will feel that
this is not everything
we are not rich by what we possess
but by what we can do without
an optimist is a person who sees a green
light everywhere
while a pessimist sees only the red stop
light
the truly wise person is colorblind
who reflects too much will accomplish
little
eventually All Things fall into place
until then
laugh at the confusion live for the
moments and know everything happens for
a reason
if we suspect that a man is lying we
should pretend to believe him
for then he becomes bold and assured
lies more vigorously
and is unmasked
the most spiritual people experienced by
far the most painful tragedies
but this is precisely why they honor
life
because it provides them with their
greatest adversities
at 20. everyone has the face that God
gave them
at 40 the face that life gave them
and at 60. the face they earned
the lack of young men
is that they think they are more happy
or unhappy
than they really are
wealth is like seawater
the more we drink the thirstier we
become
and the same is true of Fame
whoever attaches a lot of value to the
opinions of others pays them too much
honor
an evil person cannot be happy
for being alone with himself
he remains alone with the villain
happiness is the only thing that doubles
when you share it
the results of the voyage does not
depend on the speed of the ship
but on whether or not it keeps a true
course
[Music]
you should be careful not to form a very
favorable opinion about a person at
first acquaintance
otherwise in most cases
you will have to be disappointed
[Music]
many people know they are unhappy
but even more people don't know they are
happy
the more kind a person is the less he
notices the bad in people
if you own something you cannot give
away
then you don't own it it owns you
hope in reality is the worst of all
evils
because it prolongs the torments of man
the future comes slowly
the present flies
and the past stands still forever
he who cannot obey himself will be
commanded
that is the nature of living creatures
to become what one is
one must not have the faintest notion
what one is
in the hopes of reaching the moon men
failed to see the flowers that Blossom
at their feet
no one can construct for you the bridge
upon which precisely you must cross the
stream of life no one
but yourself alone
to live is to suffer to survive is to
find some meaning in the suffering
that which does not kill us
makes us stronger
if you punish a child for what is bad
and reward for what is good
then he will do good for the sake of
profit
the clever are not so much looking for
loneliness as they avoid the fuss
created by fools
the greatest of Follies is to sacrifice
health for any other kind of happiness
there is no such thing as chance
and what seems to us more accidents
Springs from the deepest source of
Destiny
willpower is to the mind like a strong
blind man who carries on his shoulders
a lame man who can see
the first 40 years of life gives us the
text
the next 30 Supply the commentary on it
the surest way to corrupt a youth is to
instruct him to hold in higher esteem
those who think alike than those who
think differently
it is not thoughts that need to be
taught
but thinking
sleep is the interest we have to pay on
the capital which is called an at death
and the higher the rate of interest and
more regularly it is paid
the further the date of redemption is
postponed
respond to critiques with
accomplishments
from the point of view of Youth
life is an endless future
from the point of view of old age it is
a very short past
don't tell your friend what your enemy
shouldn't know
if they gossip about you
it means that you are enough not only
for yourself
but also for others
an intelligent person always hides three
things about himself
his weaknesses his sources of wisdom
and his true aspirations
a man can be himself only so long as he
is alone
and if he does not love solitude
he will not love freedom
for it is only when he is alone
that he is really free
the reading of all good books is like a
conversation with the finest minds of
past centuries
he who is cruel to animals becomes hard
also in his dealings with men
we can judge the heart of a man by his
treatment of animals
The Secret of reaping the greatest
fruitfulness
and the greatest enjoyment from life
is to live Dangerously
a high degree of intellect tends to make
a man unsocial
the advantage of a bad memory is that
one enjoys several times the same good
things for the first time
it is in the treatment of Trifles
that a person shows what they are